Привет! Поздравляю с началом нового модуля, он называется Visual Engineer. Он про то,
как дизайнер работает с генеративными моделями: Majorney, Nano Banana Pro, Luxe, Cree и так далее.
Давай быстро отметим, где мы сейчас на карте программы. В первом модуле мы собирали данные,
проводили исследования, брифинг, персоны и так далее. Собрали PRD — документ,
который четко говорит, что мы делаем и для кого. В следующем модуле мы превратили это в систему
продуктов Figma, информационная архитектура, дизайн-системы, финальные макеты. Получили
Figma files с уже практически готовым продуктом, в котором только не хватает немного визуала.
В этом же модуле этим визуалом мы займёмся, разберёмся, что работает лучше, как это работает,
как получать качественный, воспроизводимый, хороший результат. И дальше будет четвертый модуль,
в котором мы оживим всю эту систему — код, диплой, агенты, но это потом. Итак,
главная идея модуля — это важно, потому что дальше всё будет крутиться вокруг неё. Дизайнеры часто
работают с генеративными моделями по одной схеме. Открываешь Mid Journey или ChatGPT, пишешь prompt,
ждёшь. Если получилось — здорово, если не получилось — переписываешь prompt. Ждёшь снова — получаешь
какой-то результат. В общем, это игра «Угадай настроение модели». В личном эксперименте такой
подход, конечно, работает, но в продакшене он рассыпается, потому что в продакшене нужно
не одну красивую картинку, а серию из десяти иконок в одном стиле, иллюстрации для пустых
состояний, которые между собой будут смотреться консистентно, баннер с текстом на трёх языках,
которые читаются одинаково везде, продуктовый шот, который повторяется в каталоге сто раз с разным
товаром. Ну и в целом возможность объяснить, почему именно такой визуал и как мы дойдём до следующего.
С подходом «закинул prompt и надеешься, что получится» — такое, конечно, не собрать. А если и получится
что-то хорошее, то будет проблема с тем, чтобы это воспроизвести. А через месяц вы вообще уже не
вспомните, какой prompt использовали, как добились этого результата и в какой модели. Поэтому решение у
нас тут одно — относиться к визуалу как к пайплайну. Это цепочка управляемых шагов, задача, выбор модели,
промт, генерация, доработка, нодовая сборка, апскейл и какой-то конечный результат. На каждом шаге
свои инструменты и свои решения. Каждый шаг можно повторить, заменить и запустить пакетно, если мы
используем нодовую генерацию. То есть в чём вся концепция нашего подхода в этом модуле. Мы рассматриваем,
как это вообще в принципе работает и уже потом переходим к делу. А не просто перебираем самые
актуальные инструменты, что-то в них генерируем и идём дальше. Это и есть инженерный взгляд на
визуал. Дизайнер перестаёт быть оператором одной модели и становится инженером пайплайна. Отсюда
и название модуля Visual Engineer. Звучит на самом деле сложнее, чем оно есть на практике. По
мере уроков всё становится привычным быстро. Итак, что нас ждёт дальше? Модуль построен по
принципу: сначала база, которая не устаревает, потом конкретные инструменты, как
примеры её применения. Первый блок - это корневая теория. Сначала разбираемся, какие вообще бывают
модели, как они устроены, какие архитектуры существуют, как этими моделями пользоваться,
где там их найти и так далее. Это всё методический фундамент, без которого выбор инструмента - это
просто стрельба наугад. Потом базовые подходы к генерации: text to image, image to image, дорисовка,
редактирование и так далее. Второй блок - это Prompt Engineering, анатомия Prompt на 5 слотах. Второй блок - это Prompt Engineering,
анатомия промпта, как вообще промпты писать, чем они отличаются, для каких моделей и какие использовать,
и отдельно JSON-промпты для серии, воспроизводимости, точечного редактирования и так далее. Третий
блок - самое интересное. Конкретные инструменты, каждый в связке со своей ключевой задачей.
Midjourney - в связке с иллюстрациями в едином стиле, там его сильная сторона. Этот инструмент
обязательно нужно будет купить. И Kreo - большой главный мульти-инструмент модуля. Там и Real-Time Canvas, то есть в режиме реального времени,
скетчинг и генерация визуалов, и upscale, и нодовые модели, и огромное количество, в принципе, моделей. Короче,
штука очень объемная, крутая, и она нам точно понадобится для прохождения модуля. Это такой швейцарский
нож. И финальный блок модуля - это нодовая генерация. Сначала концептуальный урок, что такое
нодовый подход, в чем разница между Prompt и Graph, зачем дизайнеру это, в принципе, нужно. И потом
два урока с нодовыми моделями - в Kreo и FigmaViv. Сравним, что из этих инструментов когда использовать,
где сильные и слабые стороны и так далее. И нужно ли вообще покупать отдельный инструмент. Разберем
основные шаблоны взаимодействия, построим свой pipeline и разберемся, как это работает. В нодовом
блоке, по сути, будет все, что вы освоили в предыдущих блоках. В них мы разбирались, как это работает,
какие модели использовать, как генерировать, как редактировать, апскейлить, модифицировать и так
далее. Но делать мы это будем в разных местах, в разных инструментах и так далее. Нодовая
генерация позволяет нам в одном месте pipeline всего этого процесса выстроить и его воспроизводить
сколько угодно раз. И, конечно, чтобы к такому результату прийти, нужно сначала разобраться,
как это отдельно работает, потом уже объединять эти знания вот в такой нодовый процесс. Ну и замыкается
модуль, как обычно, курсовым проектом. Это виртуальный пак для вашего сквозного продукта,
того же продукта, что вы делали в качестве курсового в предыдущих модулях. Полностью визуально
упаковываем его. Итак, стэк инструментов модуля. Что нам точно пригодится? Минимум,
который точно нужен - это Majorney и Crea. На Majorney хватит тарифа Basic за 10 долларов в месяц,
на Crea тариф Pro за 35 долларов в месяц. Это самая база, то, что нам точно необходимо. Забегая
вперед, скажу, что вот Crea - это мульти-инструмент, в котором огромное количество моделей, весь функционал,
все эти принципы и подходы, о которых мы говорим, там можно попробовать, воспроизвести и так далее.
А Majorney - это отличный инструмент для создания именно стилистики. То есть, он из коробки дает очень крутой результат,
который сам в других моделях ты бы очень долго выводил. У него отличное чувство вкуса, но редактируемости
практически в нем нет. В Crea же огромное количество моделей, хороших моделей,
но таких, которые будут настолько креативными - нет. Соответственно, если у тебя Majorney без Crea, то у тебя крутой
результат без какого-либо контроля над ним. Если же у тебя Crea без Majorney, то у тебя куча возможностей,
классный результат, но все равно не того стилистический уровня, который был бы с Majorney.
Ну и второе - это то, что по желанию. Figma Veef - это инструмент нодовой генерации, он посильнее, чем та нодовая генерация,
которая предусмотрена в Crea, которая идет в подписке с ней, потому что Veef, ну в принципе, создан именно как нодовый генератор.
Если Crea - это агрегатор вообще всего, что есть, то Figma Veef целенаправленно работает с нодами.
Он делает это круче, но для того, чтобы с нодами разобраться, покупать эту подписку не обязательно.
Также ChatGPT+ - на самом деле очень дешево можно на платимаркете купить подписку на месяц, лишним это не будет.
У GPT отличные модели генерации визуалов, очень высокая точность, поэтому стоит не поскупиться, все-таки взять подписку,
но это вовсе не обязательно. И Google AI Pro, скорее всего, у тебя уже он есть, если ты покупаешь,
если ты покупал Antigravity. Если нет, то не страшно. Ну, по сути, мы там получаем доступ к Nano Banana прямо сразу в чате с Gemini.
Там ты генерировать можешь практически бесконечно, но на самом деле в Crea тоже есть доступ к Banana 2, Banana Pro,
просто там у тебя расходуются токены. Поэтому к следующему уроку нам необходимо оформить Midjourney и Crea.
Ссылки, где мы сами покупаем подписки на эти модели, будут в описании к уроку.
Итак, в конце модуля у вас на столе визуальный пак вашего продукта в едином стиле,
очень нодовый граф в Figma VIF или в Crea Nodes, который собирает этот визуал, который можно переиспользовать
бесконечно в новых задачах. И полное понимание генерации визуала, как это вообще в целом все устроено,
и навык собирать полноценный pipeline для генерации вообще какого угодно результата с получением ровно того,
что тебе нужно, а не просто бесконечной ротации каких-то промптов.
В следующем уроке мы начинаем с корневой теории, разберемся, как вообще устроены генеративные модели,
какие бывают архитектуры, чем диффузионные модели отличаются от гипритных и так далее.
Это база, на которую дальше опирается вся практика модуля.
Домашнего задания к этому уроку не будет, но нужно приобрести подписки, о которых я ранее сказал.
Увидимся в следующем уроке.